Here's another ribber cast on that is
stretchy, pretty, and easy to work.
Similar to a single bed E-Wrap cast on,
we're using it for 1x1 ribbing.
Now you need some skills
before you start this one.
You need to have a basic 1x1 cast on of your choice.
You'll be casting on with waste yarn.
You need to know how to set your machine
for circular or tubular knitting.
And understanding how to E-wrap helps.
To make this cast on easier,
start with scrap and ravel.
Cast on in 1x1 ribbing in any
method that you'd like,
and hang your ribbon cast on comb.
Knit a few rows,
and then end your scrap
with a circular row of ravel cord.
Knit across the main bed only
with the ravel cord, then knit across
the ribber only with ravel cord.
Secure the ends of the ravel cord
and end with the carriage on the right.
Change to your main yarn and e-wrap over
all needles, alternating between the main
bed needles and the ribber needles.
Pulling the needles all the way out helps
prevent mistakenly wrapping
around the gate pegs.
Wrap counterclockwise around the needles,
trying to keep the wraps somewhat loose.
Thread up your carriage with your main
yarn, set your desired tension,
and knit across those E-wrapped stitches.
That first row may be difficult to knit,
but scrapping on makes this easier.
The cast on comb and weights are
in the scrap, not directly in the E-wraps.
Continue knitting and mark the side
of the knitting that is facing you.
Drop the work from the machine and examine
the right and wrong sides
of that cast-on edge.
Notice that the side that was facing you
has small purl bumps, but the cast-on
edge that was away from you is neater.
The difference isn't too noticeable,
but you might want to keep this in mind
when you're planning your garment.